Traduttore: Marco Pisoni
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera.
Buonasera a tutti.
Io avevo un sogno,
che si è realizzato
e che vorrei condividere
con voi, oggi qui.
È il sogno dell'Internet
delle cose sottomarine,
dell'Internet of Underwater Things,
dell'Internet degli abissi.
Una sfida tecnologica
che fino a qualche anno fa sembrava degna
di un romanzo di fantascienza,
per le difficoltà intrinseche
nello sviluppare tecnologie affidabili,
in grado di operare
efficacemente e affidabilmente
in un dominio naturale così ostile
e difficile da raggiungere per l'uomo.
Eppure, scoprire tramite sensori,
e robot sottomarini
connessi in rete fra loro,
le meraviglie di questo mondo
è qualcosa di intrinsecamente legato
al nostro modo di essere uomini.
Cosa distingue l'uomo
dalle altre specie viventi?
La sua naturale curiosità.
Da quando siamo bambini,
abbiamo una naturale curiosità,
una nostra voglia di conoscere,
di superare le attuali
barriere della conoscenza.
Ciascuno nasce un po' esploratore.
E in realtà, negli ultimi 25 anni
le tecnologie ci hanno permesso
di superare molte di queste barriere.
Sembra quasi che con l'Internet of Things,
le tecnologie satellitari,
ormai niente sia più ignoto,
attorno a noi.
Bene, questo è vero.
Ma ci dimentichiamo quei due terzi
del nostro pianeta coperti d'acqua.
E questo desiderio di scoperta
trova la sua massima espressione
in queste tecnologie
di cui vi parlerò oggi:
l'Internet of Underwater Things.
Il mondo marino è un mondo
che ha sempre affascinato
esploratori, scrittori, ricercatori
negli ultimi cinque secoli.
Se pensiamo a Leonardo da Vinci,
lo scienziato di riferimento, diciamo -
forse lo stereotipo,
l'idea stessa dello scienziato -
cinque secoli fa Leonardo da Vinci
nel suo Codice Atlantico,
vergò il primo disegno di una macchina
in grado di portare l'uomo
sotto la superficie del mare.
E non riuscì ovviamente a realizzarla:
era un'idea veramente
fantascientifica, a quei tempi.
Ma un secolo dopo qualcuno ci riuscì,
consentendo all'uomo, per la prima volta,
di esplorare i fondali del Tamigi,
in Inghilterra, davanti a Giorgio I.
E da allora è cominciata
una vera e propria corsa
alla scoperta del mare
che poi ha coinvolto tantissimi
scienziati, esploratori, scrittori
che veramente sono rimasti affascinati
e che hanno dato
dei contributi veramente notevoli
all'immaginario collettivo relativo
a questo mondo così misterioso.
Uno, ovviamente, è Jules Verne
con le sue "Ventimila
leghe sotto al mare",
di cui vedete qui una frase
che è molto significativa,
perché ci ricorda il ruolo
che questo ambiente, l'ambiente marino,
svolge nella nostra vita.
I mari, gli oceani, i laghi
coprono oltre due terzi
del nostro pianeta.
Svolgono un ruolo essenziale
nella circolazione dell'ossigeno
e ospitano la maggior parte
di specie viventi
sul nostro pianeta conosciute.
E molte, probabilmente, non le conosciamo,
perché in realtà i nostri sensi
non arrivano al di là
del confine della superficie del mare.
Quindi è semplicemente
un ambito che conosciamo poco,
pochissimo, per la verità:
qui vedete rappresentato
il nostro pianeta dallo spazio.
Quale miglior evidenza, per renderci conto
che anche se siamo abituati
all'ambito terrestre
la maggior parte del nostro pianeta
è coperta d'acqua.
E che conosciamo molto meno
dei lontani pianeti, come Marte.
Negli ultimi anni, sapete tutti,
ci sono state delle incredibili scoperte:
siamo stati in grado
di mandare diversi lander su Marte,
qui vedete un collage
di alcune foto riprese.
Questi lander hanno mandato
migliaia di foto relative a Marte,
sono stati presi vari campioni,
e come per Marte anche per altri pianeti,
quali Mercurio o Venere,
la Nasa ha fatto varie missioni
che hanno permesso di mapparli.
Eppure, se pensiamo al nostro pianeta,
di quei due terzi del pianeta
coperti d'acqua
noi conosciamo solo il 5%,
in questo momento.
Quindi, quella dell'ambiente marino
è la vera frontiera della scoperta,
la vera frontiera dell'esplorazione
che ancora ci rimane da affrontare.
Perché è così importante?
È importante perché
questo ambiente ha dentro di sé
le risposte essenziali
per il nostro futuro.
OK?
Se pensiamo ai grossi temi
che noi e i nostri figli
dovremo affrontare, nei prossimi decenni,
quali ad esempio:
cibo per un'umanità
che continua a crescere;
come affrontare, come risolvere
il problema del cambiamento climatico;
come ottenere le risorse naturali
che servono per lo sviluppo
dell'industria.
Tutti grossissimi temi.
Ebbene, molte di queste domande
richiedono, per la loro risposta,
una comprensione, una conoscenza
e potenzialmente
lo sfruttamento sostenibile
delle risorse offerte
dai mari e degli oceani.
E quindi, come avete
sentito parlare già più volte
dell'Internet of Things,
dell'Internet delle cose attorno a noi,
be', l'idea è quella di estendere
la capacità di monitoraggio
dell'internet delle cose
anche all'ambiente marino.
Perché è una cosa
così difficile da realizzare?
Perché in realtà non possiamo utilizzare
nessuna delle tecnologie utilizzate
per l'ambiente terrestre.
Le onde radio, ad esempio,
che ci permettono di interconnettere
tutti i dispositivi attorno a noi
nelle nostre smart city,
non si possono propagare
nell'ambiente marino.
E quindi cosa dobbiamo fare?
Dobbiamo utilizzare
il metodo di comunicazione
utilizzato e selezionato
dai mammiferi marini
in milioni di anni:
le comunicazioni acustiche.
E questo porta tantissime sfide,
che vedete illustrate in questo video.
In particolare,
abbiamo bisogno di realizzare:
sensori particolari
in grado di operare
nelle profondità marine,
di misurare i vari parametri,
quali la temperatura, la salinità,
le correnti, il pH
per comprendere
l'acidificazione degli oceani;
e robot sottomarini,
che possono essere dispiegati facilmente
da un gommone come quello
con cui andiamo in vacanza,
possono scoprire gli uni gli altri,
creare una rete di comunicazione,
scambiarsi senza fili
le informazioni, in tempo reale,
per poter agire come una squadra.
E insieme, sotto il controllo dell'uomo,
svolgere dei compiti complessi
che sarebbe stato impossibile
svolgere fino ad adesso,
o che sarebbe stato
estremamente complesso, costoso
o pericoloso per l'uomo svolgere.
Aprendo delle possibilità incredibili
per la scoperta dei fondali marini,
per la scoperta di questo mondo,
fornendoci la possibilità
di estendere i nostri sensi
al di là di quello
che è un confine fisico,
al di là di quello che è
il confine della superficie marina.
Qui lo vedete
in una sperimentazione reale
che abbiamo fatto,
affascinante perché in realtà
si tratta del supporto a degli archeologi
che in un sito archeologico sommerso,
in Italia, a Marzamemi, in Sicilia,
hanno avuto la possibilità
di utilizzare un team
di questi robot sottomarini
per scoprire nuovi reperti.
In realtà una delle maggiori soddisfazioni
è stato proprio il fatto
che ci siamo riusciti.
In un sito che era
stato scavato, ben noto,
siamo riusciti a trovare nuovi reperti
grazie alla possibilità
di estendere i nostri sensi,
alla possibilità dei robot sottomarini
di vedere quello che c'era
al di là del fondale.
Se andiamo alla prossima, grazie.
Allora, quali sono, per esempio,
i robot sottomarini?
Li vedete qui rappresentati,
i robot sottomarini, nella prossima slide.
E qui vedete una bellissima
colonna romana,
che faceva parte del sito
di Marzamemi, che citavo prima.
L'aspetto essenziale
è il fatto che l'uomo è al centro.
Queste tecnologie ci permettono
di superare i nostri confini fisici:
ma siamo noi che dobbiamo sfruttare
tecnologie come sensori
e robot sottomarini
per la nostra fase di scoperta.
E poi, queste tecnologie
possono anche essere utilizzate
per consentirci di sperimentare
in maniera più ricca
la nostra dimensione
all'interno del mondo marino.
Quindi possono aumentare
la sicurezza dei sub
fornendo informazioni in tempo reale
sullo stato di sicurezza del sub stesso,
o come in questa foto,
che è una foto reale,
possono consentire all'uomo
di condividere informazioni sui social
anche mentre sta facendo un'immersione.
È anche una bellissima storia,
credo, contro gli stereotipi.
Innanzitutto è una storia
di ricerca al femminile
perché si basa su un'idea femminile:
io sono molto fiera
di far parte di questo progetto,
"100 donne contro gli stereotipi"
che sollecita le giovani donne
a seguire la passione di tante donne
impegnate nella scienza
e [nella] tecnologia.
È anche una storia di giovani.
Di giovani dotati di talento, energia,
che hanno fatto loro questo sogno,
questa visione, questo entusiasmo.
E hanno deciso
di dedicare le loro vite, qui,
alla realizzazione
di questa sfida tecnologica.
È una storia contro gli stereotipi,
perché è una storia di cervelli rientrati,
ed è una storia di cervelli
come i miei ragazzi,
i ragazzi del mio gruppo,
senza i quali non sarebbero -
non avremmo mai raggiunto
questi obiettivi.
Che avevano avuto
tante opportunità all'estero
e che hanno scelto, invece,
di realizzare pienamente
le loro aspirazioni di carriera
qui in Italia.
È una storia di Europa,
che per una volta veramente dà valore
perché è una storia di una ricerca
che è stata finanziata, negli anni,
grazie alla vittoria
di fondi competitivi europei.
E in particolare, l'ultimo finanziamento
che abbiamo preso
è un finanziamento della cosiddetta
European Agency For SME,
Agenzia Europea per l'Innovazione
nelle Piccole e Medie Imprese.
Quindi questo ha consentito anche
di creare una spin off de "La Sapienza"
in cui questi giovani di cui vi raccontavo
stanno mettendo le loro energie
per portare realmente, nel mondo reale
nel cosiddetto mercato,
le soluzioni che abbiamo sviluppato.
All'interno di un progetto
quale ARCHEOSUb,
che mette insieme due aspetti
del nostro essere italiani:
beni culturali e tecnologia.
Quindi sviluppare tecnologie
per il monitoraggio, e la sorveglianza,
la verifica dello stato di conservazione
e la valorizzazione
dei beni archeologici sommersi:
oltre mille attorno
alle coste dell'Italia,
non sfruttati e non sorvegliati.
È una storia quindi
di "Made in Italy" un po' diverso:
non si tratta della pasta,
né della Nutella,
non si tratta del design.
Ma di tecnologie che nascono da qui,
che sono sviluppate qui
e che poi esportiamo con tante richieste
da industrie e governi esteri.
Perché?
Perché queste tecnologie sono al cuore
di un cambiamento paradigmatico
nella blue economy, l'economia del mare.
E sempre più le risorse che ci servono
vengono da questo mondo.
Se pensiamo al cibo,
per un'umanità che cresce,
se pensiamo ai cosmetici,
se pensiamo alle medicine,
moltissime di queste risorse naturali
e minerali preziosi,
moltissimo di quello che ci serve
viene ormai dall'ambiente marino.
Ed è un economia che vale
centinaia di miliardi di euro,
5.000.000 di posti di lavoro
nella sola Europa,
in cui in questo momento
siamo protagonisti
di un cambiamento tecnologico
per rendere più competitiva
questa economia,
per abbassare i costi,
per aumentare quello che può essere fatto
per sfruttare in modo sostenibile
l'ambiente marino.
Quali sono le applicazioni?
Potenzialmente infinite.
Dal comprendere questo mondo,
e quindi comprendere veramente
la tettonica del nostro pianeta,
diciamo fenomeni come il vulcanismo
in ambito sottomarino
a potere in maniera efficace
controllare i nostri confini marittimi,
o reagire nel momento
in cui avvengono dei disastri naturali
o eventi come il naufragio
della Costa Concordia.
Inoltre, lo sviluppo
di sistemi per il monitoraggio
e l'ottimizzazione, per esempio,
dell'acquacultura:
centinaia di miliardi di euro.
Di nuovo, è qualcosa che è essenziale
per poter offrire il cibo
che serve all'umanità del futuro.
Inoltre, il monitoraggio
delle fasi di estrazione,
delle fasi di trasporto
di petrolio, gas naturale;
o il monitoraggio di infrastrutture
marine quali i porti.
Oppure, ancora,
il mondo meraviglioso,
veramente affascinante,
dell'archeologia marina.
Cousteau diceva
che nel momento in cui ha avuto
la possibilità di vedere nel mare
la sua vita non è stata più la stessa,
non ha più potuto concepire la vita,
pensare, vivere nello stesso modo.
Con questa frase ha condiviso
con noi un emozione,
nel momento in cui è stato in grado
di superare i suoi limiti.
E ora noi, io, vorrei -
io e il mio gruppo
vorremmo condividere con voi oggi
questa emozione
di aver sviluppato tecnologie
che permetteranno alla prossima
generazione di esploratori,
quindi l'uomo al centro, nel 2030,
di poter fino in fondo esplorare
questa parte così grande
del nostro pianeta.
E spero che, magari,
alcuni dei giovani esploratori
siano fra i vostri ragazzi,
i vostri bambini,
proprio qui da Foggia.
Grazie.
(Applausi)